Every day, Ruhul Amin retraces his daughter's last footsteps ... the daughter he lost.
The 35-year-old fled the massacres in Myanmar and crossed over, with his family, on foot.
He had built a shelter made out of bamboo and tarp in Kutupalong camp in Cox's Bazar, in Bangladesh.
Then the rains came. And tragedy struck
There were heavy storms. Even before monsoon season began. The rains pelted the roof of their hand-made shelter.
Huddled together in their makeshift home, the family needed fuel to cook a simple meal of rice and stew.
And, in the refugee camp,
children are often sent to collect the firewood. It's a chore that can last from sunrise to sunset.
Ruhul remembers the day his seven-year-old daughter Aziza Begum set off early one morning in May 2018.
While Aziza, her older sister Romiza, their cousin Momina and their two friends were gathering firewood,
disaster-hit.
The two friends saved themselves, by digging out of the torrent of mud and shouted for help.
But Aziza, her sister, and cousin were still trapped.
A little farther away, four boys were playing soccer. When they heard the cries for help, they rushed to the scene.
The three girls were taken to the hospital. And when news reached him, Ruhul rushed there too.
What happened to Aziza is a constant fear for people living in the refugee camp.
While Aziza was the first recorded fatality,
a few weeks later a two-and-a-half year old boy died when a wall of mud fell on him.
And it was reported that a Rohingya man died when he was hit by a tree that had been weakened by rainfall.
Even if it doesn't kill them, Rohingya refugees live with the fear of the monsoon destroying what little they have managed to build.
Shelters are risk of being swept away during the rainy season, pitched on sandy clay soil.
Since May 2018,
there are almost 50,000 refugees living in shelters in areas that are at high risk of landslide.
Fewer than half have been relocated to safer settlements. And safety is what drove Ruhul to flee in the first place.
He had brought his family to Bangladesh to escape all the violence his people were facing in Myanmar.
After escaping all this, he'd now lost a child.
These scattered mementos in the family tent – a cup,
her schoolbooks, the toys she shared – are all that's left of Aziza.
A reminder of a friend, a sister, a daughter.